you're listening to an encore
presentation of Bible answers live
however if you want to order any
materials offered during tonight's
program you may call our resource number
anytime at
[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact Jeff Bezos the founder of
amazon.com is now the richest person in
modern history according to the
Bloomberg billionaires index as of July
2018 his net worth past 150 billion
dollars that's about 55 billion dollars
more than Bill Gates the world's second
richest person B's o--'s crossed the
threshold following an Amazon summer
sales event just this year his net worth
has soared by 52 billion dollars which
is now more than the entire fortune of
the richest person in Asia it also put V
Zoe's personal fortune just behind the
entire Walton family heirs of the
Walmart dynasty who are worth a hundred
and fifty 1.5 billion it's estimated
that in 2018 Jeff Bezos earned
approximately two hundred and seventy
five million a day behind B sells on the
Bloomberg index is Bill Gates with a
ninety five point five billion fortune
followed by warren buffett with a eighty
three billion bill Gates would still be
the richest man in the world except he
and his wife Melinda gave away billions
of dollars to their foundation after all
how many billions of dollars you
actually need to be comfortable stay
with his friends we'll talk about it on
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 hundred radio
stations we're on satellite radio around
the country and also we're streaming on
the amazing facts Facebook page and the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page and you can
text your friends right now and tell
them tune in with a Bible question my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross good evening friends and pastor
Doug let's start the program with prayer
dear father we thank you for the
opportunity once again to open up your
word and study together we ask your
blessing upon our time guide us in a
clear understanding of what the Bible
says for we ask this in Jesus name Amen
amen pastor I open the program by
talking about someone who has a lot of
money I mean we talking not just about
millions we're talking about billions
there not 1 or 2 billion we're talking
about what 90 plus billion dollars owned
by one man incredible they used to
believe that if you had a billion
dollars you'd never have to work again
and of course that was true but now with
inflation the price of average price in
California think for homes like half a
million dollars and so now that the key
is be the billionaire who wants to be a
billionaire but you know for the
Christian there's a really simple
principle you should earn all you can
save all you can and give all you can
and you need wisdom to ascertain that
balance but we should not strive simply
to be rich the Bible
says that those who make haste to be
rich will not be innocent and some
people have been very successful and God
has blessed them but they're also
generous and you can read about this
when you go to first Timothy chapter 6
I'll start with verse 6 now godliness
with contentment is great gain for we
brought nothing into this world and it's
certain we can carry nothing out and
having food and clothing with these
things we should be content but those
who desire to be rich will fall into
temptation and a snare and into many
foolish and harmful lusts that drown men
in destruction and perdition for the
love of money doesn't say money but the
love of money is the root of all kinds
of evil for which some have strayed from
the faith in their greediness and have
pierced themselves through with many
sorrows jesus said a man's life does not
consist in the abundance of what he
possesses key for a Christian is you
know God wants to bless us and the
secret is you need to be willing to be a
channel of blessing the Lord is more
inclined to put things in the hands of
people who will transfer things into the
hands of those in need and so the Lord
if as we've got one hand open as we're
working and we're doing all we can to
earn we should also have another hand
open so we are channels of blessing to
the world and the Bible teaches these
principles about Christian work now
there's a commandment says rest one day
a week 4th commandment but it also says
work six days a week and the Bible says
those who do not work should not eat so
God wants us to be productive but he
also wants us to be generous and we have
a special lesson that talks about those
principles for anyone we do it is a
study guide entitled In God We Trust
it's all about money what does the Bible
have to say about money
jesus said quite a bit about money and
how we use money who happy to send this
lesson to anyone who calls and asks the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
our resource phone line again 800 eight
three five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the study guide called In
God We Trust with happy to send it to
you in North America if you're listening
out
out of North America I know we have
those folks listening on Facebook you
can actually go to the amazing facts
website just amazing facts so are G and
you'll be able to read this study guide
for free online again it's called
in god we trust' well pastor before we
go to the phone lines we don't often do
this but somebody handed me a question
this person is very faithful listening
to by the Lancers live they said could
you please ask pastor Douglas question I
said okay we'll do that so here's the
question first question for this evening
it says I understand that the Holy
Spirit will be withdrawn from the earth
during the time of trouble will we still
have the protection of angels during
that time and will God still answer our
prayers during this time of trouble okay
I think the person is talking about a
verse where you read in I said 2nd
Thessalonians where it says he that now
lets will let until he's taken out of
the way the Holy Spirit has a
restraining influence on the wicked in
the world today but when probation
closes that restraining influence to
some extent will be withdrawn and
there's going to be time of trouble such
as there never has been but what about
God's people will we still have angels
to protect us I think without God's
guardian angels the wicked angels would
pretty quickly destroy us and so you
know we're always going to need angels
and especially during the time of the
seven last plagues you read in Psalm 91
that neither shall any plague come nigh
into your dwelling only with your eyes
will you see and behold the destruction
of the wicked he will give his angels
charge over you to keep you in all of
you your way so I think definitely God
will have his angels watching over us
absolutely we have the promise reading
in Psalms where it says during that time
of trouble God will send his angels to
watch over us and no plague will come
near your dwelling so that's a wonderful
promise really go to the phone lines our
first caller this evening I think we
have Thomas listening from Lady Lake
Florida Thomas welcome to the program
well thank you pastor Dagon appreciate
it thank you I have a question about
Hebrews six verses four through six
about once a certain person is
enlightened and then if he falls away
it's impossible
that came back in and to be brought to
repentance again is this maybe because
he's committed the unpardonable sin that
maybe the the Holy Spirit cannot you
grieved him so he can't get back I
wonder about this first well yeah I
think that I think you're on the right
track there first of all what the verse
is not saying the verse is not saying
that a believer cannot backslide or sin
and then be forgiven because basically
that would mean the prodigal son could
never come home that would mean that
Peter after denying the Lord could not
be forgiven or David or Moses roses
didn't deny the Lord but Moses did lose
his temper and so there'd be no hope for
a whole lot of people out there if
anyone who backed slides could not be
forgiven notice the words that are being
used it says someone who has tasted the
heavenly gift become partakers of the
Holy Spirit have tasted the good word of
God the powers of the age to come if
they following and the word fall away
there is really telling us that if these
people turn away from the best that God
has to offer what more can God do to
restore them if we reject the very best
what else is God gonna send so it is
it's talking about a person who is
really grieving away the Holy Spirit
it's not something that happens in a day
or two of discouragement where all of a
sudden guy says all right well you took
your eyes off me you're doomed now does
that make sense yes it does I just
because I I've been I was baptized in
1985 and I lived some wonderful years
with a piece of price in my heart and
then I fell back into my always again
and have been like that now for over 20
years and I still attend my Adventist
Church every week and I'm a deacon and
all that but I just these problems and
it is that you don't feel like you've
got the the the the spirit and the love
that you had before right yes I don't
well you know you can the very it's the
Holy Spirit that's making you ask that
question and so you know Thomas I think
God's Spirit is wanting you to get a new
beginning and Jesus said if we've lost
our first love and I think this in his
Revelation chapter 2 if we've lost our
fur
love then we must repent and return to
the first works those first works where
you were really so excited about the
Lord you were studying his word you
spend time in prayer you were sharing
your faith and as you do those things I
think God is gonna help you renew that
experience well thank you for your Col
Thomas and our next call of the behalf
is you're gonna add something well no I
was just gonna say what can we offer
Thomas that would help him in renewing
his experience well we have several I
think one we mentioned before the
program is called the riches of His
grace it kind of talks about that that
deep commitment that one has also three
steps to heaven I was thinking the same
book also outlined some very very good
principles there so to receive the book
just give us a call 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for two books one
is called three steps to heaven and the
other is riches of His grace talking
about just the love of God and what we
can do to have that connection with him
we have William who's listening from
Syracuse New York
William welcome to the program hello how
are you Pastor Doug hi it's great to be
on how are you today and your question
oh my question okay my question I'm
sorry my question was I've been watching
pastor Doug's by a search and I got this
prophecy cold seminar that I got in the
DVD and I was watching clothed with
light and I've been watching it over and
over and over notice it's inspiring me
and everything and there's a question
that pastor Doug quoted and I don't know
if he's quoting from a different
translation because I try to find it it
says you didn't give me it says right
here oh if they will fear me and keep
all of my Commandments all the time that
it will be well with them and their
children I was wondering if he was
quoting that from a different verse
because I try to find it in the King
James Version and the New King James
Version and I couldn't find the word Oh
Deuteronomy I think you're gonna find
that in let me see here Deuteronomy
chapter 5 yes and verse 29 chapter 5 you
know because it's strange because you
know I'm a minister out here in Syracuse
and I've been sharing all your wonderful
DVDs and I've been sharing it people and
they'll be actually there when you get
to study man is also my didn't know
nothing about this I didn't know nothing
about that and I've been
all over Syracuse plus you're hurt yeah
some other people call me crazy because
they see me that I'm a to domination my
family so my family's from Israel and
then I got a Spanish ID on and they look
at me like two different assessments and
sometimes some of the best Michael I
know your background I know that your
mother was Jewish and then at the same
time your father I didn't know what it
was but I know he was Baptist I think
and it's pretty much like me you know
and that's why a lot of people and I
actually bring some of the truth to them
like once you what you bring on these
seminars and stuff like that in
enlightens it's like lift up a burden
because God wants us to know the truth
you know because God is not going to be
a hypocrite and Holy Spirit to
contradict one thing in the Bible then
you know try to change something in
another and I took people that God is
the same yesterday today and forever
more he doesn't change absolutely now
you've seen the you see the verse we're
talking about in Deuteronomy 29 let me
read this to you
oh that they had such a heart in them
that they would fear me and always keep
all of my Commandments that it might be
well with them and their children and I
think that probably William in the
prophecy code sermon that you heard me
quoting I was probably quoting from the
King James Version but it's almost
identical here hey we really thank you
for your call but we got a line up here
are folks with questions you keep up the
good work and you know we do have a
lesson that talks about the commandments
it's called written in stone we'll send
you a free copy yes the number to call
is 883 five six seven four seven after
the study guy called written in stone
we've got Chris listening in California
Chris welcome to the program
hello gentlemen hi how are you good
thanks for calling and your question my
question is is the military would that
be considered a civil service that's
something that me and my family have
disagreed on I've been in the Marine
Corps for over 10 years as an instrument
deployed to Afghanistan and all that but
my family say that the military well the
MOS that I'm in is not considered a
civil service like paramedics police and
all that well there's no question we're
thankful for those who have served in
the military I have a son that's served
in the Marines and you know I typically
I would not recommend
and that a young person trying to live a
Christian life would enlist in the
military simply because the military
almost is your god when you join they
say look we give the orders and you
might say well today is my time for
church and they'll say no well we're you
know we're doing something else today
and it can it can be pretty difficult to
fulfill your some of your Christian
values and again I'm not saying that to
show any disrespect for the military but
it can there can be some real conflicts
there as a Christian when you sort of
sign over your choices to such a big
Department military is not an emergency
service like a doctor you know for
instance on the Sabbath they doctors
don't leave the hospitals and nurses
leave the patients and nursing homes and
there's a lot of emergency service like
that if a house catches on fire we're so
glad that there's a fireman who'll come
but Menino I don't think I'd put the
military in the same category that
because it's 365 days a year
any thoughts on that path for us well
you know yes we do have those who are
Christians and they serve in the
military although as pastor Doug says it
does take a certain degree of faith to
really stand up for what you believe in
and yet still do service they are those
who have been able to serve in the
ministry in various other capacities
where it doesn't require them to have to
violate any of God's commandments yeah
there was just a a pretty famous movie
came out there I think it's called
hacksaw Ridge about Desmond Das who
areas are medically he was try to
struggle for him but he held up his and
we knew him mm-hmm
held up his convictions but he got yet
persecuted a little bit for that but he
stuck to his convictions in the military
I remember I know the first I guess you
could call war here that I heard about
growing up and stuff my grandfather read
me the Stuart unlikeliest hero and stuff
exactly and that just hooked me on and I
learned as much as I could about him and
then I met him when they ever read the
book by Terry Johnson for his honor I
know I haven't
that one you can look that up it's it
that's another good book it talks about
how to live out your convictions in the
military and how how many prayers got
answered but you are kind of you're
walking out into kind of dangerous
waters when you say I want to be a
practicing Christian I want to serve
Jesus first and I'm going to do it by
joining the military because you're
gonna run into all kinds of everything
about you may not be able to eat what
you want worship when you want not shoot
somebody when you don't want to shoot
them right so a lot of challenges hey
Chris I hope that helps a little we got
to keep going we got two folks lined up
next color that we have is low listening
from North Carolina law welcome to the
program hi thank you I'm calling because
I am I've heard pastor Doug and you
speak about the distinction between new
wine and old wine and how the old wine
is fermented and new line is it's not
fermented and I accept that that sounds
right to me
well I was reading in Luke 539 and I was
confused because Jesus himself is
telling a parable and I guess he's
speaking for a character in his parable
at the end of 539 he says the old wine
is better and that was confusing to me
that why Jesus would say that well he
said that uh people who are used to the
old wine say the old wine is better and
that spills along with what we've been
saying is that typically the old wine
obviously new wine is never fermented
fermentation especially back then took
time the old wine was fermented and a
person who specialized their struggling
with alcohol dependency they said I am
the old wines better they've been
drinking it you know also think Jesus
bringing up an important point here he's
talking about the new wine is
representing his teaching his doctrine
versus the old wine which was the
teaching the doctrine of the Pharisees
and so Jesus says you know those who
have drunk the old wine meaning they're
boarding to the teaching and the
philosophy of the religious leaders of
his day they don't want the new wine but
he says in the verse previous new wine
must be putting new wineskins and he's
referring to the disciples who were
willing to receive the teachings and the
doctrines of Jesus so again he's just
using this as an analogy talking about
truth right not being settled in your
ways people like what they're used to
and
I think it was Mark Twain that said
nobody likes change except a baby and
sometimes they don't like it so he's
just making an algea something that
they're familiar with already and
applying it to his words yeah the the
scribes and Pharisees were settled into
this regiment of traditions and for and
they had these interpretations of the
prophecies that were wrong and for Jesus
to give the right teaching of the gospel
he needed fresh vessels that were open
that weren't all rooted and entrenched
in their old ways so he's calling the
old ways the old traditions the old wine
okay all right that makes more sense to
me thank you thank you so much
appreciate your call next caller that we
have is Peter or listening in New Jersey
Peter welcome to the program good
evening gentlemen I had a question about
if God has an appointed age that each
one of us are going to die which cannot
be altered or changed why is it that
certain people who exercise and take
vitamins and maybe eat a vegetarian type
of diet tend to live longer than those
that don't
well I would not say that God has an
appointed age I don't think the God
arbitrarily says you know what I I you
know flip the dice and I've decided
you're gonna die at 65 I think that
there's cause and effect God said do not
be deceived whatever you sow you will
reap and if a person sews a life of
irresponsible habits they will reap an
early death if a person sews a life of
taking care of their body temple and
glorifying God and what they eat and
drink they will reap a longer life and
so III don't think that God just picks a
number on a calendar and says I'm just
deciding regardless of your choices this
is when you're gonna die
I do think our choices affect the length
of our life well that's very interesting
I'm glad I quote can I ask you one more
question and then all I'll hang up and
listen over the radio can you give us
some insights into the new heaven and a
new earth what it's going to be like
does it have any similarity to how we
live now or will we be like this
embodied spirits floating into heaven
etc thank you yeah thank you very much
and we appreciate your question yes in
heaven the Bible says God is going to
restore his original plan for this
planet God took very real humans and he
put them in a garden Adam and Eve were
spiritual creatures but they were also
physical creatures after sin they sort
of the spiritual dimension was damaged
that will be restored in heaven but
God's gonna make a new heaven a new
earth Isaiah says there'll be animals
there Isaiah 11 you can read in Isaiah
65 it also tells us we will go forth and
build houses and inhabit them we will
plant vineyards and eat the fruit of
them God's gonna have us doing real
things and a beautiful glorious world
with real bodies and enjoying things
Paul says our eyes have not even seen
the wonders that God is preparing for
those that love him and of course the
Bible tells us that the redeemed will
have bodies matter of fact Philippians
chapter 3 verse 21 says who speaking of
Christ will transform our lowly body
bodies that it might be conformed to his
glorious body so when Jesus rose from
the dead he had a glorified body and the
Bible says those are the kind of bodies
we're gonna have when Jesus comes and he
in front of the disciples he ate he said
touch me I am NOT a spirit with spirit
doesn't have flesh and bone as I have he
emphasized he was real the Bible talks
about the tree of life people who eat
the fruit they're off so we have a
lesson we can send you if you'd like it
talks about heaven is that the wonderful
colossal city lost in space yes yes to
receive that lesson give us a call the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you're gonna ask to the study guide
called a colossal city in space next
caller that we have is listening from
let's see we've got Carol in Rockland
Carol welcome to the program hi Carol
you're on the air and your question Oh
my question is is cremation acceptable
to God as a way to treat our body after
death alright great question you know
there really is no command in the Bible
that you shall bury and you shall not
cremate the example in the Bible if you
were going to look at
circumstantial evidence typically people
were buried the patriarchs Abraham Isaac
and Barrett and Jacob were buried a
matter of fact even Joseph and Jacob
were embalmed before they were buried
there are a couple of cases where person
believers were cremated such as the son
of Saul and Saul but typically the the
ancient church believed that because man
was made in the image of God that even
in death he still board God's image and
it was typically the heathen that would
cremate or burn and scatter the ashes
now some some may be saying well the
Bible says ashes to ashes dust to dust
he turned to ashes and dust anyway
cremation sort of accelerates the
process nobody I believe is going to be
excluded from the resurrection because
God cannot find all the pieces to put
them back together again he's going to
give them a new glorified body so many
martyrs were burnt for their faith and
their ashes were scattered does that
mean God is not going to be able to
reassemble or resurrect them of course
not
anyway so I I kind of went on both sides
of a wandering trail their hope that
helps a little bit and we thank you
Carol for your question next caller that
we have these areas listening from New
York areas welcome to the program name
and your question oh well first want to
ask how you guys doing good how are you
doing I don't pay ten is my first time
calling in you know all right well we
got about two minutes for your questions
so let's go and put it out there okay so
I have a best friend or you know a
friend so I'm just really trying to find
a way how I should kind of show these
some different truths of the Bible it's
like she knows she knows some of them
right and I'm kinda like her technically
teacher or some like that and I'm just
wondering like okay how am I gonna teach
her about like some of the things that
you know like let's say let's say dress
reform health reform it works like that
you know well first thing I'd ask Aires
how she accepted Jesus oh yeah that's
the first thing if a person has fall
love with Jesus first thing you want to
present before you present any of the
difficult doctrines or standards about
like whether it's you know dress or
health the person needs to first fall in
love with Jesus and once a person has
made a decision to commit their lives to
Jesus and they really say I want I love
him I want his word I know he died for
me he gave his life I want to do
whatever is going to please him and when
they're thoroughly converted then you
present the other particular details of
the Christian faith and they're going to
be hungry for it they're gonna want to
know I forget that verse it says find
out what BES pleases the Lord and
they're gonna want to know what pleases
the Lord and they'll be doing that so do
that first and then any other doctrine
that you present to your friend do it in
the context of talking about Christ
every doctrine needs to be rooted in
Jesus for instance the reason we dress
modestly is out of love for God and our
fellow man everything should come from
that hey friends were not done we got
more questions coming be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Corrine was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Corrine to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Corrine has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend
have an opportunity to help someone
today and to make an eternal difference
for more people like Corrine you're a
simple investment of faith and amazing
facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one or just visit give dot amazing facts
dot o-r-g or send your gift to peel box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight thank you for studying the
Word of God with me today and I hope
that you'll plan now to join me again
next week as we discover more amazing
facts from the Word of God want to know
God's plan for our world and solutions
for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts
twenty seven Bible study guides provide
encouraging Bible based answers to
questions on healthier relationships
when Jesus will return and much more
refer to watch while you read our brand
new prophecy encounters DVD series makes
the perfect companion set order your
study guides and DVDs today by visiting
AAF bookstore calm or by calling 858
seven two seven five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 my name is
John Ross we gonna go straight to the
phone lines we got more listening from
Hampton Virginia Maury welcome to the
program hello pastor bird hi how can we
help you tonight yeah I just had a
question um I was reading the Bible and
Jesus said that we have to basically
worship Him in spirit and in truth and
basically when I was growing up in Haiti
we should worship like a different way
and then when I came here in u.s. do we
use jumps and stuff like that and I
cannot say uncomfortable day and I just
wanted to find out if God really like
does he find pleasure in like you know
who is jealous of later all right well
first of all when Jesus talks about
worshiping in spirit or in truth
remember when Christ began teaching in
his early ministry he said they
religiously
they would fast to be seen of men they
would give blow the trumpets so everyone
would look at them they would pray and
long prayers so people would think
they're holy that was in sincere worship
Christ wants us to worship in spirit and
in truth we want to do it in our spirit
with sincerity and to worship Him truly
according to his word now you're asking
about a worship practice that's in a lot
of churches with the drums now there may
be a place for rhythm in music but
typically in the worship music they did
not have like the drums that you see in
some churches now and drums were used
often on the battlefield yes people went
marching off to war I'm I'm
uncomfortable you know a lot of what's
happening now with the music in some
churches is the worship styles and the
music is sensual in nature certain kinds
of music appeal to rhythms and stuff
that you know I don't think are
appropriate in the worship service it's
one of the more hotly disputed subjects
but yeah when I think worship styles do
matter no we actually have a book that
yeah I think you have to order this book
though at amazing facts on drums and
worship and it's actually written by a
youth pastor
I think it's worship music and drums but
you look it up at our website and I
think you'll find that give me any
thoughts on that pastor Russ yeah you
know I think you're right we want to
worship God reverently as you said there
are some appropriate uses for rhythm if
you have an orchestra yes sometimes they
will have a big set of those drums but
that's a little different than the kind
of rock and roll type drumming that we
have in the world today and we need to
be careful to avoid those things so I
agree we should as nearly as possible
try to imitate the angelic music in our
sacred worship in the church next
quarter that we have is Becky listening
from Michigan Becky welcome to the
program oh hi I wanted to wish you guys
a very Merry Christmas well thank you
likewise and your question
I have a question from a Christian point
of view how do you get along with
difficult people and how you deal with
them
well patiently Jesus said and deal with
others as you would have them deal with
you you Peter said how often shall I
forgive my brother seven times and this
is Matthew 18 Jesus said no not seven
times but seventy times seven
that doesn't mean you let people abuse
you but you know as long as a person
genuinely repents we need to be patient
and then keep in mind how patient is God
with us when we are difficult and so you
know it takes special power because I
know there are people and I think the
Lord deliberately brings people into our
lives to challenge us all so that we can
learn how to practice the Christian
virtues of love forgiveness patience
sometimes you have to bite your tongue
when you want to say something and
that's where you develop the Christian
meekness but it's hard sometimes I admit
that Becky does it help yeah it does
well thank you very much we appreciate
your question and I don't know we ought
to write a book on that that's a great
title how do you deal with difficult
people
pastor Ross is going to write a book on
that god bless you hey thank you so much
Merry Christmas thanks Becky Alex quoted
that we have is John listening in North
Carolina John welcome to the program
John you're on you might have your mute
on North Carolina and your question
Michael is based on Daniel chapter 12
verse 11 also we use these for these
comedies follow along toward this
prophecy has already beautiful fool well
you know we come from the perspective
here of what you call instead of the
futuristic view of prophecy we come from
the the perspective of what you call a
historic view of prophecy that the
prophecies of daniel and revelation are
covering a panorama of history and you
know boy there's just no
in three minutes that we can explain
Daniel chapter 12 you've got more time
prophecies in Daniel 12 than any other
chapter in the Bible we do have a lesson
that talks about the three and a half
years 1260 days it's called the time a
time and the dividing of time and it now
would that be the study on the right on
time yes that would include it because
if the first part of that is talking
about the coming of Jesus yeah if you'd
like to give us a call John we'll be
happy to send that to you just ask for
the study guide called
right on time and it gets to do these
various time prophecies past that I've
mentioned to got the 2300 days in Daniel
8:14 Daniel 12 is sort of a summary of
some of the previous time prophecies
that are given in the book it's a very
deep study but it begins by laying the
foundation and kind of building from
there so we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls the NASA's 808 three
five six seven four seven next caller
that we have is calling let's see all
the way from Australia we have salsa
listening in Australia so so welcome to
the program thank you very much how are
you today doing well thank you for
calling thank you for the opportunity so
my question is basically about some
women's clothing and I can pretty much
understand for example first Timothy to
not and how it says women should adorn
themselves with modest apparel with
propriety and moderation not with
braided hair this is the part I don't
understand the braided hair whether this
is about - the braided hair or there was
some other practice going on the jewelry
cause I'm assuming thanks we shouldn't
be wearing jewelry and then the most
confusing things I mean is the trans
issue because having GM Deuteronomy 8
years a woman shall not wear that which
pertains to a man nor shall a man put on
a woman's garment for all that do so are
an abomination that's deuteronomy's at
22 I forget mm-hmm yeah
about pants or because from what we know
and what men were at that time looks
like what's women wear nowadays so is
this about pants or well the main
principle first of all let me answer
you've asked two questions one about
Reuter here one about women's clothing
and pants in particular there is nothing
wrong with a woman in my opinion wearing
pants but what what he's saying here is
there needs to be a clear distinction in
the styles of men and women
unfortunately we are living in a culture
now that is amalgamating and erasing
distinctions of gender the whole culture
is saying that you should you know men
dress more and more effeminate and
likewise women are dressing more manly
and increased confusion God wants us to
celebrate the differences between men
and women even in Bible times men were
not - there was a difference between the
clothing of men and women that's right
said a woman was not to put on a man's
garment vice versa
today there are differences between
men's pants and women's pants I reached
in my drawer and put on a pair of pants
a couple of years ago and I knew right
away something was terribly wrong Karen
had a pair of jeans she put in my drawer
and we are built differently so and I
thought about that scripture and I was
just waiting to be smitten down by the
Lord but so you know I think that the
principle for a Christian is the pants
should be modest in for men you know
Christian should not be dressing a
clothing that is so tight and so loose
so tight and so low that nothing is left
to the imagination I think God wants
Christians to dress modestly and as far
as the broidered here that wasn't
talking about braiding your hair for a
woman to put a simple braid in her hair
just for practicality is a good idea but
they used to weave chains of gold in
their hair that was common back then and
so he's talking about these elaborate
hairdos that they were doing that was
ostentatious the idea
was not to spend a lot of time and money
on the outward adorning and neglecting
the inner man or woman in that case very
quickly about jewelry as well for
example we now are at the point in our
lives me and my husband that we don't
wear our wedding things as there is that
included in jewelry as well or it's just
a symbol that should be
well yeah very quickly first of all let
me tell you just so you get more
information I've got a book you're in
Australia you can download this it would
take probably 40 days and 40 nights to
get there by mail and it's called
jewelry how much is too much just go to
the amazing facts website and you can
download that but on the wedding ring
quick answer snow we're in the Bible and
I don't wear a ring I don't think
pastors want Ross wears a ring and we
are very married and my name is Bachelor
and I'm still very married but you know
there's no law in the Bible that says
you need to wear a wedding ring
obviously there are lots of Christian
men and women that do and so I wouldn't
make that a moral issue for them but
you're asking about what the scripture
says and there's there's nothing on that
in the Bible thank you very much Sosa
and we appreciate your call next caller
that we have is Rose listening from
American Samoa Rose welcome to the
program hi pastor Doug hi hey Rose I'm
supposed to be there in Samoa in 2020 oh
yeah we got invited there look it looks
like we're gonna make it to Samoa in
about a year and a half so maybe we'll
see you then but your question tonight
okay so my dad isn't a believer so he
doesn't observe the Sabbath and just
yesterday we ran out of milk something
we don't necessarily need but he went
ahead and bought it he meant well but
I'm worried about consuming something
purchased during the Sabbath I wouldn't
worry about that
I mean you didn't when you think about
it you know for Christian and people
listening my thing one of these cookie
people talking about in the Bible
you know the Sabbath is one of the Ten
Commandments and part of sabbath-keeping
it says you shouldn't buy or sell and so
I think Rose is wondering well someone
in the family bought something on the
Sabbath does that mean if I drink the
milk I'm gonna get worms or something
technically when you go to the market
and you buy milk you don't know that the
person who owns the market bought it on
the right day of the week so you're only
responsible for decisions you make and
you know you can't control all the
decisions everybody else makes and so
that would I guess that would be my
answer to that well you know pastor day
it was the situation back in Bible times
that Paul addressed they were believes
that would buy food or meat at the
marketplace and some of the things that
they bought had been offered to idols by
the pagans and then they bought the food
from well that concerns some and Paul
was saying well you know you weren't
there it's not your fault that they
might have offered it to the to the idol
if it's good food and it's acceptable to
eat then you know buy it and pray and
eat it so exactly we're all responsible
for own decisions like you say yeah good
question thanks for your call rose our
next caller to behave is Roger listening
from Colorado
Roger welcome to the program hello thank
you for accepting my call again yeah
question
somebody told me that we are in the
kingdom of God right now for numbers
taken in Luke 17 verse 22 23 he says the
kingdom is at hand I think it says that
are we in the kingdom of God now yes
that's a trick question let me tell you
why well it's not a trick question but
it's a confusing question because there
two answers there is a physical Kingdom
and a spiritual Kingdom when Jesus came
John the Baptist began to preach repent
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand
meaning within reach it's here Christ
began preaching the same thing kingdom
of heaven is at hand the spiritual
Kingdom accepting Jesus as your Savior
all of us can have Christ reigning in
our hearts now but clearly there will be
a day when Jesus returns and the new
jerusalem descends he receives a kingdom
from his father he will fill the whole
earth that's the message of Daniel
chapter 2 and the literal Kingdom will
fill the earth at that time so when we
pray the Lord's Prayer thy kingdom come
we're talking about the future literal
Kingdom but when we accept Jesus the
spiritual Kingdom allows him to be king
in our hearts so good question Roger
hope that helped a little bit yeah you
helped me quite a bit thank you very
much thank you
next caller that we have is Charles
listening from Newport Florida Charles
welcome to the program
hey I've actually call before I actually
have a question about the Sabbath as far
as working we usually do like it we're
like struggling trying to get all the
housework done before you know sundown
on the Sabbath but what about as far as
like washing dishes like normal like
everyday housework like if you have
issues you don't want to either let them
sit and everything else until the follow
and you know till the following night
that's a good practical question yeah
yeah and you know you need wisdom when
the whole idea is you want to avoid any
unnecessary work because it's a day of
rest it's a holy day I had a friend I
asked the same question pastor and the
wife that baptized me many years ago I
said no what about you know keeping the
Sabbath business I said what about doing
dishes she said well when we lived in
the mission field in Burma if you didn't
at least rinse your dishes you had all
kinds of animals and critters that were
coming through your house and she said
you know you want to just do what you
need to do to honor God and keep things
clean and so you know you might rinse
them and throw them in the dishwasher
and just keep things sanitary Moses does
talk about doing things even on the
Sabbath that keep the camp holy the
priests used to do some cleaning in the
sanctuary even on the Sabbath day to
keep things holy and presentable and so
I wouldn't be run on my vacuum cleaner
but you know if my kid spills Cheerios
on the floor I might so that's the idea
get everything out of the way that you
can ahead of time God is not walking
around with the binoculars to see if you
you know you you know wipe the dust off
a book or something
right well me this is basically just
pretty much me out you know we don't run
a vacuum or do like any major work or
anything you know it's just a whole
dishes thing it's kind of caught me off
guard I'm like well we have dishes
sitting on the counter I'm like and I'm
gonna like leave him all night and then
in our home we just we rinse them you
know for eating our last meal of the day
we just wait until after savage then we
do it and or if you know it's earlier
you might just rinse the food and stack
and we wash them later you just try and
keep things in order and do as little as
possible because it's a day of rest
okay I kind of like the idea of leaving
the dishes seems like someone else shows
up and cleans them if I just leave them
no I do a lot of dishes in my home yeah
recently I just read your book the
richest caveman and I gotta say me once
I started I couldn't put it down
you know I literally read it in two days
that that is one of the nicest things
people say is I meet men all the time
you say you know I never read a book in
my life but once I started your book I
had to finish it I don't know what it is
when I read the book it doesn't do that
to me but I'm always thrilled when I
hear that hey thank you so much Charles
we sure appreciate your call mix one of
their babies Katherine listening from
Houston Texas Katherine welcome to the
program hello how are y'all doing well
how are you doing good um I love your
show thank you they're such a blessing
for me but I had a question that I'm
kind of confused on so when you died
where does your breath go and is your
breath your spirit so I don't know
there's I'm kind of confused on that
well the word breath and spirit are kind
of interchangeable in the Old Testament
it talks about the Spirit of God it's
the very same word for breath it's raw
and it says God breathed into Adams
nostrils the breath of life and then it
talks about in Joby says the Spirit of
God in my nostrils same word the breath
of life so when a person dies you read
in Ecclesiastes chapter 12 the spirit
the breath returns to God who gave it
the body returns to the earthly elements
it decomposes ashes to ashes dust to
dust
so it's like when you say when you
unplug a lamp where does the light go
well where's the electricity go it goes
back to the Power Company where it came
from you know what I mean yeah yeah so
it's not that you know suddenly the the
light has become disembodied and it's
floating around away from the lamp the
way that we do our thinking is when the
breath of life is in our bodies in our
brains
when we die we are sleeping a dreamless
unconscious sleep until the resurrection
it'll seem like a moment for us it's
gonna seem you know as soon as you die
you're present with the Lord if you're
saved but you know the resurrection
hasn't happened yet until the Second
Coming does that help so it does so it
just so like when Jesus comes again and
so does the breath come back to you or
yeah he'll breathe into these
resurrected bodies he gives us now if
you're alive when he comes you get in a
moment you get a new body if you're dead
when Jesus comes the dead in Christ rise
it won't seem long for them it's gonna
seem like instant from the time they
died and they come out of their graves
with glorified bodies he breathes that
breath of life back into them you know
we do have a website I just wanna
mention Catherine I think you'd really
enjoy it I'm looking at right now all
you have to do is just typing truth
about death com or death truth and I
think we're one of the first if you
google that and I'll show up one of the
first sites that you find it tells you
all about it it gives you all the Bible
references there's actually video that
you can watch on the subject just a
really great study it's called
truth about death com next caller that
we have let's see we've got Tom
listening from Lincoln Nebraska Tom
welcome to the program hello thank you
this might be a whole sermon of itself
but my question was and I'm sure you
guys probably empathize with this but
why is it that seeing how the Lord has
given promises to protect his people why
is it that people who are inside the
church become victimized and incredibly
traumatized
from abuse that happens from inside
these different churches now do you
believe in God yes do you believe
there's a devil oh yeah if you are the
devil and you wanted to do as much
damage to the church as you could you
would try to release your agents in the
church to misrepresent it just like
there was a Judas even in Jesus Twelve
Apostles so the devil has his
representatives that prey upon the sheep
he Jesus called them wolves in sheep's
clothing so that sums it up pretty well
doesn't it mm-hmm
you've got people that they pretend
they're Christians and they go into
church and whether it's you know we all
have heard about some of the the abuse
that has happened to children with
pastors or priests there's people who
claim to be Christians that are stealing
money from their flock and they're you
know fly in fancy jets and and they're
just fleecing the sheep and they're
wolves who are exploiting the Sheep
that's because the devil is making war
against the church it's certainly not
Jesus teaching and it's not his pattern
but if I was a devil that's what I'd do
is I'd start trying to misrepresent the
church by having hypocrites in there
right yeah so have you experienced that
yourself where you feel like people in
the church have been abusive or taken
advantage people people I love that yeah
yeah it's terrible when that happens
because what they do then is they say if
that's what God is like or they say if
that's what the church is like and they
turn away from you know Jesus he loves
the church and there's a lot of
wonderful people in the church and a
Church's place of healing
but you know some people have a bad
experience and the devil allows that so
they become discouraged with the church
and they turn away hey I hope that helps
a little bit Tom we do have a study
guide that talks about clothed with
light we'll send you a free copy of that
if you call the number and I'm gonna
call these eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven ask for the
study guide called clothed with light
it's all about the church and I think
you'll find that helpful again eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and do we have time for one more
call
it's called the two-minute buzzer so we
got it real quick all right dainty we've
got just a few minutes you on the air
you're there don't be calling Tennessee
Deonte Deonte sorry Oh
Deonte yes so real quick it's gotta be
good question today yes sir I wanted to
actually I had two questions they're
going to be quick oh well the number one
was my sprain I have a couple Catholic
friends and I wanted to come about the
you know the prophecies in the Bible to
them to explain to them that the Beast
theory that if God is explained in the
book of Revelation is actually the Roman
Catholic Church I don't want to like you
know just force it onto them I want to
ease it once ago so if nuclear light all
right with that let me do my best to try
and touch on that we may not get to your
second question because we have one
minute left if you want to share the
Protestant view of prophecy and you may
know that many of the Protestant leaders
like Calvin Martin Luther John Wesley
Roger Williams
swingley John Knox they were all
Catholic priests or many of them were
Catholic priests they believed that the
Catholic Church had become corrupt and
it was the fulfillment of Revelation
chapter 17 now when a Catholic reads
that or hear that it can be
earth-shaking you need to reason to that
gently and you know one thing I'd say is
they could get them our study that talks
about that subject team it's we got to
study God you can send for and have them
pray make sure they first accepted Jesus
before you get them into some of these
heavy prophetic studies and we've got
who is the Antichrist is one and it's
not our teaching this is the universal
prophecy our Protestant teaching for
many years sorry that's all we can do
tonight on your question beyond tea god
bless you friends hey this is the
holiday season what do you do for us
this time of year keeps us going all
year go to amazing fact so our G God
bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
divorce but that's when God led them to
an amazing fax broadcast and there they
saw the biblical view of marriage as
presented in knowing Jesus finally they
understood what it meant to love
sacrificially like Christ and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
will keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that you've
learned and it's easy to make a donation
just visit give dot amazing facts to RG
or send your gift to peel box
10:58 Roseville California 9 5 6 7 8 you
can also give us a call at eight seven
seven five zero six one seven five one
the number again eight seven seven five
zero six one seven five one thank you
for tuning in to Bible answers live and
don't forget to share with others the
amazing Bible facts you have learned
here today written by the hand of God
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
[Music]
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 to 75 or visit AF bookstore
com4 life-changing christian resources
visit AF bookstore com
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF as a RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]